-Our next guest
is a writer, director,
and an Emmy Award-nominated
actor you know
from his work in shows
such as "Escape at Dannemora"
and films like "The Batman"
and "The Fabelmans."
He stars in "Dumb Money,"
which is in theaters
and on demand now.
Let's take a look.
-Hey, do you -- do you
remember back at Stonehill
when they dared me
to run that mile naked?
-Yeah, there was
a crazy storm that night.
-Everybody remembers that.
-Okay.
-They do, man.
You don't think people
remember your 4:03 mile?
-Oh, what is this? A pep talk?
-Stop hiding. Seriously. Okay?
Stop being all meek and [bleep]
and running away.
-What? You want me to run
through lightning
with my [bleep] out?
-Yeah. Please. Exactly that.
Run through lightning
with your [bleep] out.
[Bleep] it.
-Please welcome back to
the show Paul Dano, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-How's it going?
-It's great.
It's great to have you back.
I really love this film.
This is about the GameStop --
I don't want to say scandal.
-Stock saga.
-The stock saga.
-Yeah.
-Exactly.
And, yet,
this is the second time
we've had someone
from the movie on,
and we keep showing
the clip of Pete Davidson
talking about [bleep]
Which is
a very small part of this movie.
-It's -- Well, it's a big small
part of the film, Seth.
-It's a big small part.
You've said it correctly.
-If you're Pete Davidson,
it's easy to tell other people
to run around with their
[bleep] out, I guess.
-Yeah. You you did play --
The actual person
you played in the movie,
Keith Gill --
he was a runner in high school.
This is a true thing.
-He was a runner.
In fact, I think he got
a scholarship running.
I decided to start to run,
you know, to get into shape
and feel like a real actor.
And I started waking up
before my kids got up.
I'd go to the track behind
the school that's closest to us.
And then I get to work
to go film the scene,
and we are, indeed, filming on
a track that's behind a school.
But the track where
we're actually filming on
is behind a high school,
and it turns out the track
that I was running on
was behind an elementary school.
-Oh, gotcha.
-And they're
two different sizes.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, I was -- You know,
if I did like four laps
on the elementary-school track,
I felt pretty good about myself.
-Yeah.
-And doing one lap
on the high-school track,
I didn't feel so good
about myself, so...
-It was -- I will say,
through movie magic.
I thought you were
a pretty believable runner.
So well done.
-Thanks. Yeah.
-I like, though,
that you showed up to set
and you're like,
"I can do four laps."
And then you're like, "I might
have gotten that wrong."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Now, you know, I remember
this story as it was happening,
but I will also admit
to not fully
comprehending the details of it.
How well did you know
this story?
-I didn't know it well.
I probably listened to, like,
the episode on "The Daily"
that was like, "This
GameStop thing is happening,"
and that was actually
one of the pleasures of
the script was going,
"You know, okay, wow.
This is actually fascinating.
It's a real story."
It's a "subculture,"
but it's like 8 million people
strong on Reddit
who sort of rose up
against Wall Street
and actually took it
to The Man for a moment.
You know, a lot of these firms
and these hedge funds,
now they have to hire people
just to track
what people are doing online,
people who they used
to make fun of
and think we're
shark bait for them.
And now they actually
have to pay attention, so...
-We had the writers
on during the actors' strike,
because it's very hard
to promote a film like this
that has such a wonderful cast.
Nick Offerman, Seth Rogen,
yourself, Pete Davidson,
obviously, Shailene Woodley.
-Yeah.
-But we had Lauren Schuker Blum
and Rebecca Angelo.
They're former journalists.
Did it feel like, when you were
reading the script, like,
"Oh, I can tell
that they're both great,
like, sort of scriptwriters,
but also have
a journalism background"?
-Well, I don't know
that I knew that,
but it was really thorough
and thorough
in, like, a concise way,
which is not --
So, as you could tell
the way I'm telling this story,
that's not my forte.
Like, how do you sort of
make that information?
Also, how do you make that
information like action, right?
So that it's super-fun to watch
and that you're also
sort of taking in
and learning something.
And, again,
I enjoyed learning about it.
I mean, I was not even on social
media before doing this film.
And then I thought, "Well, okay,
I have to get in touch.
Like, I have to be a person
who's in touch with the world."
So I made these
social-media accounts.
And, like, I watched --
I ended up watching these videos
that people made during
the GameStop phenomena
every morning
before I went to set.
People made songs.
They made these videos.
They made these mash-ups.
And that, like, energized me.
I had to take the energy of the
people and bring it to work.
-And it was -- Because it was
a real sense of community.
I think that when we think
about the stock market,
we think about all --
it's all based on sort of greed
and avarice and making money.
But this GameStop story
was a group of people
that there was sort of
a collective sense of,
"We're doing something bigger
than just making cash."
-Yeah. And this was also
during the pandemic,
and I think people needed
something to, like, believe in.
They needed something
to get behind.
And one of the things
I loved about my guy,
whose name is Keith Gill,
who went by Roaring Kitty,
is just how honest he was.
And I feel like the stock market
is a lot of smoke and mirrors,
right?
And he was not that.
He was like, "No, this is me.
You can literally watch me trade
for three hours online.
Here's my spreadsheet.
Here's my account transparency.
Like, look."
And that realness,
I think, meant a lot to people.
-So, you did some running.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You did some social accounts.
Did some social.
-Can we assume now that
you're a giant stock trader?
-Just --
That's been my strike job.
You know, three monitors
-Yeah.
It's hard to picture you
without a headset, really.
-No, I'm actually terrified
of that.
I hate gambling.
I hate losing money.
And if I was to get into that,
I am the type of person
who I have to get obsessed
and go, like, all out.
So I would stop
what my current job is
and I would have
to commit to that,
and that is not something
I want to commit to.
I'd rather go make a movie.
-Yeah.
-Or if you commit to it,
it's, like, a real bummer
to have to go tell your family.
Like, "I know I've been doing
acting for a long time,
but I think I got a new itch."
This was the other thing
about this movie,
and it's really impressive,
is how quickly
it was turned around,
because this is about
very recent history.
And, you know,
you've made movies
based on things
that have happened in the past,
but I'm assuming
you've never made something
that happened
in such the recent past.
-I don't think so.
And the way information
moves nowadays,
just in the news and online,
you got to get in there.
You got to jump on it.
And, again, it's weird that --
It's weird that there's so many
pieces of recent history
that mean so much
to so many people,
and, yet, I can come here
and just say,
"Oh, I just heard about it
on 'The Daily' and --"
Yeah, but I think
there's, like --
There was a real pleasure
in the sort of modern element
of this for me,
as opposed to a period piece,
like "The Fabelmans"
or something,
where I think I just got to
bring, like, a lot of myself
to work
and to be around guys like Pete
and just, like, be a dude.
And the movie's funny.
And so I had a really good time.
-You did not reach out
to Keith Gill.
-No.
-What was your reasoning
behind that?
-Well, okay, so,
it was the guy who I play.
Basically, Wall Street kind of
teamed up on him, ultimately.
He got deposed by Congress
and he had to testify
against a bunch of billionaires
with all their lawyers.
And this is just, you know,
sort of an
average-but-extraordinary guy.
It felt like he needed to step
away from what he was doing,
and it just felt like the vibe
he was putting out
was not a "Come stand outside
my house" vibe
and track me down.
It was a "I need
to step away for a moment
because of what's happened."
And I can't -- This happened,
again, during the pandemic,
so the deposition, which you
can see it was on Zoom,
but, I mean, this is a guy --
If I got called in
to testify in front of
the senators, you know,
and billionaires -- terrifying.
So I just wanted
to respect his space.
-I think that was
the kind and correct choice.
Last time you were here
was around the holidays,
and your daughter --
Not to bring up,
you know, a painful memory.
Pink eye last time.
Are you more hopeful
about these holidays?
-That's right.
I came out and gave you a pound
and I was like, "Don't worry.
I washed my hands."
Yeah, no, no, no,
I love the holidays.
I love Thanksgiving.
I love this time of year
here in New York.
-Do you have
a big Thanksgiving?
-We do. We have my dad.
We have like 50 to 60 people
every year.
-50 to 60.
-Yeah. Yeah.
And they're people
I only see once a year.
And, sadly, the pandemic,
we kind of had
a couple years off,
which, again,
it's people I only see --
It's basically a family reunion
every Thanksgiving.
One of my cousins,
thankfully, has reorganized.
And there's pictures
that predate my existence,
from the '70s,
of this Thanksgiving.
So the the
Dano family Thanksgiving --
it's a real thing.
We take a photo together
every year.
You can see everybody growing.
For me, it's really beautiful.
So it's probably
my favorite holiday.
-Where do you guys do it?
Where in the country?
-In Pennsylvania.
And do you have to --
Is your role as one of the 60 --
do you have
to bring something?
Do you have to cook some food?
-You know, so, my --
I probably should.
-Yeah. Because it seems.
like you really love it
and it's very important to you,
and, yet, you're just
kind of freeloading.
-Because I grew up going,
I think I'm taking, you know,
my young self
and thinking that my adults
are still going to
provide for me.
I'm going bring
something really nice this year.
-I did say to my --
I said to my wife,
"You know, it's funny --
like, growing up,
like, Thanksgiving was always
my favorite holiday."
And she's like,
"That's because you were a kid
and you didn't have to do
anything."
-Right.
-She's like, "Your memory
is, like, a false memory.
Now you're an adult,
you have to get up off your ass.
I'm sorry."
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I do dishes.
-Oh, that's really sweet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks. Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-Now, I feel like we've --
When we've been here and we've
talked about your work,
you know, "The Batman,"
"Escape from Dannemora,"
which I loved so much,
your kids --
have you done anything
yet your kids can watch?
-Ah. No.
I mean, even this one, you got
Pete running around naked.
You know,
I can't show that to them.
-Yeah.
-No. It would be fun to.
That's, like, really where
I'm at in my life right now,
especially this strike year
is, like --
you know, I got a 1-year-old
and a 5-year-old --
is be with my kids.
It would be fun to do something
that they could watch.
They don't know what we do,
even our 5-year-old,
which I like.
But it's funny that --
I don't know if it's just
what kids do
or if they intuit it,
but she said for her birthday,
which is, like, next summer,
but we're already planning it,
she wants to be a costume party.
She wants to write a story
and have everybody
act it out for the party.
And I was like,
"Okay, is that just you?
Is that somehow, like --"
It's amazing, yeah.
-What does she think you do?
-I think she thinks I'm
somebody who's on a computer.
-Okay.
So, she's like,
"What does your dad do?"
She's like, "Computer."
-Computer.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"He's very good at computer."
-Yeah.
-Well, it's a wonderful --
I hope one day, you make
something that they can watch
or they'll just get old enough
and enjoy your current work.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Thanks so much, Paul.
-Thanks. Yeah.
-Paul Dano, everybody.
"Dumb Money" is in theaters
and on demand now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."